[Musique]
bienvenue sur la face cachée de la lune
messieurs steam guard dans tes prières
je vous aime pas un honneur d'être parmi
autant d'hommes courageux
vous croyez que le nouveau patron nous
obligera à patrouiller les environs
chaque fois qu'on nous tirera dessus
chaque fois qu'ils tirent à l'aveuglette
sur nous ils voient notre réaction
quand les vrais méchants arrivants
nous connaîtrons parker
[Musique]
notre travail est de séparer les
talibans des citoyens ordinaires tout ce
que les américains semblent c'est
d'abord sur leur chemin je peux vous
donner de l'argent
des contrats des projets
s'ils vont collaborer
[Musique]
on fait de grands progrès ici à kamdesh
mais beaucoup de travail reste à faire
notre avant postes
reste une cible pour les insurgés
comment faire votre travail est resté
sain et sauf
il se prépare
combien
plusieurs noms ce troc est
et mener une vie de périmètre
c'est trop dangereux puis débridé
on va vous sortir de la pièce jointe
cache toi
doit reprendre le camp
on doit continuer de nous battre
tu vas pas mourir
là sont les meilleurs amis que tu te
feras jamais